there's a brand new article out in the
wall street journal and it is probably
the most insane article you're going to
read in all of 2022. now of course this
article breaks down that there are
477 workers employed by the bureau of
labor statistics and their job is
literally to go to small businesses
grocery stores and corporations and
simply write down on a piece of paper on
a tablet what's the price of various
goods at those stores now when they go
and do this there's a lot of complexity
involved imagine going to the grocery
store and having to help measure
inflation but your job is to go fine
soup but make sure that it's not low
sodium or high sodium that it's no
sodium soup and you got to make sure you
get the right brand and you've got to
get the right number of ounces and so of
course there is human error and in the
21st century we're counting on
individuals with a tablet or a pad of
paper to go into stores try to find an
entire grocery store the one product and
then write down what the price is and
track that month over month over month
is absolutely insane on top of that as
they're doing this they end up not only
making mistakes but they also
necessarily have no audits there's no
checking of these individuals or their
work all they do is we simply blindly
trust them that's not exactly the way
that i want my inflation calculated in
the article they talk about how shop
owners business owners and various
employees at different establishments
they continue to say that prices are out
of control their supply chains are
completely disrupted and there's no
relief on the way this is the perfect
example is that when you have bad data
and you actually use that to make your
analysis you end up making bad decisions
the fact that in the 21st century we
have people physically walking through
stores and writing things down is insane
take something like shelter right now
the bureau of labor statistics they
literally call on the phone and they ask
people hey what's your rent hey how much
is that house worth now compare that to
something like zillow or apartment.com
which has a 100 million plus data points
and in real time they see the adjustment
on various prices and where the market
is actually clearing or where people
have their asking price of course zillow
an apartment.com and many other
providers even companies like square
they have way more data it's real time
and it is verifiable i'd much rather
trust the technology companies than the
individuals walking through the grocery
store with a pad of paper or a tablet
manually inputting numbers we have to
build a better system we have to stop
trusting the cpi number it's a
manipulated number that's based on human
error and of course the federal reserve
they're simply just using the data they
have available to them if we get better
data we'll get better analysis which
leads to better decision making but
until we get better data we have bad
data which leaves a bad analysis which
leaves a bad decision making and that
means that you at home the average
american individual that's why there's
eight and a half percent inflation and
it's not going away because ultimately
nobody knows what the real number is
nobody knows what they need to do or how
extreme the response should be we're
looking at bad data and therefore you
can't solve a problem until the data
improves